they kind of curl down and i don't have
the wrist strength to even hold my
wrists out straight his muscle strength
is weak in his hands his legs too
forcing the lake country man to wear
these braces they're just an insole they
slide in
in my shoe ross whiteman suffers from
guillain-barre syndrome a rare condition
affecting the nervous system i
had paralysis from the waist down
and full facial paralysis as well he was
diagnosed with a days after receiving
his first shot of the astrazeneca covet
19 vaccine last spring and spent 67 days
in hospital
now the federal government has validated
his vaccine-related injury with a
successful claim for compensation making
him among the first in canada to be
approved for the benefit i'd rather not
be in that club in a heartbeat it's it's
nice to have some recognition and
there's vindication the vaccine injury
support program was established more
than a year ago to offer financial
support for people like white men the
vaccine injury support program website
has not been updated recently by the
federal government but it does show the
number of claims submitted and approved
in the first six months of the program
between june 1st 2021 and november 30th
there were 400 claims submitted less
than five of those were approved by a
medical review board it's indicative of
our
persistence with the program and you
know every week or every two weeks
phoning emailing
what's happening do you have all the
paperwork you need while whiteman won't
go into details as to how much he's
receiving he said the maximum lump sum
payout is 284 thousand dollars an amount
he did not qualify for he's also
eligible for 90 000 a year for loss of
income and while the former realtor is
relieved to be getting compensation it's
less than the amount he was making
before the injury everyone has a
lifestyle that they're used to or have
budget towards you know
especially with kids and whatnot and and
so
that's going to be something that we're
going to have to kind of figure out
where to go
from there whiteman doesn't know if and
when he will work again for now he's
focusing on his recovery going to rehab
twice a week and celebrating the small
victories
i'm
grateful to have
some mobility back an optimism about
continuing to get better claudia van
number global news kalona